welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Marvel Studios newest announced
Disney plus series will be Wonder Man
founder of the West Coast Avengers and
possibly finally the answer of how white
Vision Paul Bettany could return in the
MCU after he blasted off again in one
division like many lost Jersey Boys who
get their brains broken and need some
vitamin D this guy's like I'm headed out
California way cause you're always like
us baby we will
Wonder
oh boy I'm the boss not the boss The
Hollywood Reporter broke the news this
week that xiangxi director Destin Daniel
credit is teaming up with writer from
Brooklyn Nine-Nine community and your
guest to bring Wonder Man to Disney plus
and if you're like my folks your first
reaction might have been why there's
actually a very good reason I'm gonna
explain why Simon Williams in the world
that he occupies including Vision the
West Coast Avengers Zemo the
Thunderbolts actually fits in pretty
well with Marvel's plans and could be a
Marvel take on some of the best content
on TV right now why wonder man could
essentially be a love letter to
television the way one division turned
out to be the mcu's Barry but
co-starring She-Hulk Bucky Zemo and Val
I mean what's not to love about that
technically Simon Williams already
appeared in the MCU on a movie poster
from a deleted scene in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 a biopic biopic biopic
person movie titled Tony Stark a lot
Danny Boyles Steve Jobs with Simon
Williams starring as Tony Stark James
Gunn's buddy Nathan Fillion did a photo
shoot for a bunch of fake movie posters
for that movie but we never actually saw
them in any of the frames the movie they
were removed but in the comics Simon
Williams was first introduced in the 60s
Avengers Comics the son of a wealthy
industrialist and rival to Stark
Industries who's got embezzling money
and imprisoned ends up teaming up with
Zemo when Zemo was running the masters
of evil Williams gets empowered with
ionic energy to become Wonder Man he
tries to Infiltrate The Avengers but
ends up siding with the Avengers against
Xeno it's kind of a common thing for
Zemo now in the years after Simon
Williams's in suspended animation and
his brother Eric Williams becomes the
Grim Reaper and uses Simon's body to
attack The Avengers than years after
that Ultron creates vision and he
actually uses the brain waves of Simon
Williams to give Vision his personality
so yes folks in Marvel lore Simon
Williams is a key component of what we
know Vision to be and you may remember
when we were Neck Deep In One Division
theories and the wonderful time of early
2021 a few Easter eggs in that series
included overt references to the Grim
Reaper not to mention the parallels to
the West Coast Avengers storyline in the
creation of white vision and one man
really came into a Zone in that 80s
storyline as the founder of the West
Coast Avengers when Simon moves to Los
Angeles to pursue a career in Hollywood
as a stunt actor and that is why I think
Marvel Studios is moving forward with
this wonder man title because it picks
up with these West Coast Avenger and
Grim Reaper clues that weren't left as
loose ends in one Division and if the
MCU version of Simon Williams is simply
white vision from One Division it would
give us an exciting New Direction for
this synthazoid a one division season
1.5 alongside AKA The House of Harkness
and a fun companion series to titles
like armor Wars Thunderbolts and a sort
of shung chi follow-up hell it could
even give us a great way to redeem Ralph
boner from Westview I know it sounds
impossible but hear me out so the
synthazoid known as white Vision in the
MCU is of course a product of sword and
director Hayward using the corpse of
vision recovered after Thanos killed him
in wakanda in Infinity War pulling apart
his body made up of vibranium atoms
fused with Helen Cho's artificial tissue
in each Voltron Hayward reconstructed it
and charged it with radiation that won
the maximoff left on a Stark Industries
weapon I his drone that she tossed out
of Westview like a mean neighbor
throwing back a frisbee that landed in
her yard now back in the MCU as we saw
in Age of Ultron Visions personality
really came from Tony Stark's AI of
Jarvis not Simon Williams brainwaves but
this way white vision from One Division
could be Marvel Studios way of
deconstructing and retroactively
generating the Simon Williams Persona
within another Vision body played by
Paul Bettany in this case containing
Visions memories but one less attached
to one to maximoff and this vision's
origin moment was really that ship of
Theseus debate with the Westview Vision
identity in the one division finale what
is that the ship of thesis neither is
the true shift both of the true shift of
course that scene ended with white
Vision confused blasting out of a
skylight never to be seen again leaving
us wondering if he might reappear as a
sentient weapon in armor Wars or maybe
mentoring the Young Avengers but to be
honest none of those really sounded that
exciting to me rather the prospect of
white Vision heading west of Westview to
establish the mcu's West Coast Avengers
as he applies his talent to Hollywood
action movie sets as stunt muscle trying
to find his soul sounds exactly like the
kind of comedic premise that a team from
Brooklyn Nine-Nine and this young Chi
director would work wonders with and
make a name like Wonder Man pretty
hilarious when paired with Paul
bettany's vacant mouth breathing and if
you think about it this is very much the
premise of HBO's Barry one of my
favorite series on television right now
in which Bill Hader plays a violent
Hitman who tries to find his soul by
taking acting classes in Hollywood now
if they end up not doing the white
Vision Paul Bettany route Bill Hader
along with Nathan Fillion would be
pretty great choices for Wonder Man if
you ask me but if we go to the white
Vision Direction white vision's interest
in the film and television industry
could come from his experience being
imprinted upon by a vision who was
generated in a hex modeled on famous
Hollywood sitcoms the last of which
episode 6 and 7 were based on Malcolm in
the Middle and Modern Family Matt
shackman even shot the Westview
exteriors in Burbank on the Warner
Brothers Colonial Street Lot which was
used in a ton of TV shows as opposed to
where every other Marvel Disney Plus
show is shot on Disney's Pinewood
studioslot in Atlanta Matt shackman
shows the Burbank set to give Westview
that classic TV sitcom artificiality so
white vision's activation moment was
meant to reflect ultron's Awakening when
Ultron rapidly scanned through Decades
of news footage white Visions parallel
Awakening could be rooted in TV sitcom
history leaving him with a Fascination
and appreciation for the narrative
tropes that we saw in the episodes of
One Division and now the guy heading
west to LA to actualize those dreams
this would also be a great opportunity
to bring back Evan Peters as working
actor Ralph boner he's already got the
headshots and I think he'd be great if
Simon Williams roommate Jordan him on
auditions maybe the two even lived
together on a boat anchored in Marina
del Rey a boat named the Theseus balance
see and Simon's Life as a working actor
would be the MCU Avenger Level Threats
that we come to expect from this genre
with Simon building a West Coast Avenger
lineup composed of people like the Los
angeles-based She-Hulk the San
francisco-based Shang Chi and Carol
Danvers who did spend most of her time
in LA in Edwards Air Force Base in
California why did we see that
particular lineup in the shangshi post
credit scene directed by Destin Daniel
[ __ ] maybe this is
what they face probably the Thunderbolts
feature Marvel title that we just heard
some news about in this same week the
Thunderbolts seem like they're going to
include people like Zemo John Walker
Elaine Bulova Abomination overseen by
people like Val maybe that's why Miss
Marvel seems to be sending Bruno Corelli
Westward to Caltech so that we have a
new Young Tech wizard in California to
balance out the brainiacs like Riri
Williams in MIT of course Marvel Studios
can do a solid wonder man title without
making him white vision and yeah actors
like Nathan Philly it would make a
pretty good Simon Williams I just think
there's so much left in mind from One
Division and that white Vision backstory
makes the most sense to me let me know
your thoughts on this in the comments
below follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at avos following Rockstar subscribe to
new Rockstar some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]